OBJECT AND IT'S NOT.
IT'S FOR THE SAFETY OF
AMERICANS.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH TOMI FOR
DOING THAT JOINING US WITH
MORE ON THAT DECISION IS THE
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA
UNDER SHERIFF DON BARNES IS
WITH US.
SIR, FIRST, I WANT TO
APPLAUD YOU SECONDLY I TOOK
WHAT YOUR ATTORNEY SAID IN
CALIFORNIA AS A THREAT.
IN OTHER WORDS, HE WOULD
ALMOST INSINUATED HE MIGHT
TRY TO ARREST YOU FOR JUST
PUTTING OUT WHO IS IN JAIL
AND WHEN THEY ARE GETTING
RELEASED.
ISN'T THAT LEGAL?
>> WELL, IT IS COMPLETELY
LEGAL.
UNDER THE LAW WAS PASSED
UNDER SENATE BILL 54 54 THERE
IS A PROVISION CLEARLY
CANNOT DO.
CANNOT COMMUNICATE WITH
ENFORCEMENT BUT IT SAYS WE
CAN MAKE THIS INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT WE
HAVE DONE WE ARE FOLLOWING
THE LAW AND HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO FOLLOW THE
LAW.
DOESN'T THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, OAKLAND MAYOR
ICE WAS TRYING TO ENFORCE
MAYOR AGAINST CRIMINAL
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THOSE WHO COMMITTED OTHER
CRIMES BEYOND THAT WHICH WAS
NOT RESPECTING OUR LAWS AND
SOVEREIGNTY.
IF I WERE TO GIVE PEOPLE A
WARNING THAT YOU WERE ABOUT
TO GO IN AND HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR CRIMES.
WOULD WHY BE ABETTING AND
OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE?
>> POTENTIALLY.
THAT WOULD BE A LITTLE BIT
OF A STRETCH.
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE VERY
CLEARLY DOING WE ARE GOING
AFTER VERY SERIOUS OFFENDERS
WHO ARE IN CUSTODY IN OUR
JAIL.
BEING CONVICTED OF VERY
SERIOUS CRIMES.
SB-54 ALLOWS TO US NOTIFY
ICE THOSE UNDER THE TRUST
ACT WHICH WAS PASSED IN
2014.
PREVIOUSLY PASSED
LEGISLATION AND THAT'S WHAT
WE ARE DOING.
WE ARE STILL NOT PHIING ICE,
THE SHERIFF HAS THAT
DISCRETION.
LAST YEAR WE TURNED OVER
580.
WE HAVE 57,000 BOOKINGS.
SO THAT'S A SMALL PERCENTAGE
OR ACTUALLY JUST 58,000.
THIS YEAR WE HAVE ALREADY
TURNED OVER 181.
BUT 244 INDIVIDUALS WERE NOT
TURNED OVER TO ICE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
SO THEY ARE VERY SERIOUS
CRIMES AND THEY BE BEING
RETURNED BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY.
QUITE HONESTLY BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITIES THEY PREYED UPON
AND COMMITTED THEIR CRIMES
TO BEGIN WITH WE ARE TRYING
TO HELP THE COMMUNITY TO BE
SAFER BY TURNING THESE
INDIVIDUALS OVER TO ICE AND
NOT LETTING THEM RETURN TO
THE COMMUNITIES AND COMMIT
MORE CRIME.
>> Sean: DO YOU HAVE A
RESPONSE TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND THE COMMENTS
THAT HE MADE TONIGHT?
BECAUSE I TOOK THEM AS A
LITTLE THREATENING TOWARDS
YOU.
>> WELL, THEY WERE
THREATENING.
I WOULD SAY MY HOPE WOULD BE
THAT IT WOULD READ THE
LANGUAGE OF THE LAW THAT WAS
PASSED.
VERY CLEARLY SAYS IN THERE
WHAT WE CAN AND CANNOT DO.
WE CANNOT COMMUNICATE WITH
ICE IN AND OF HERSELF
RETURNING US BACK TO A
PRE-9/11 CONDITION
LEGISLATIVELY WHERE WE CAN'T
TALK WITH OTHER FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
THAT'S PROBLEMATIC ON ITS
FACE.
BUT IT ALSO HAS A PROVISION
WHERE WE CAN'T MAKE THIS
INFORMATION AVAILABLE
PUBLICLY.
IT'S INFORMATION MADE
AVAILABLE PUBLICLY AND EVERY
INMATE WITHIN OUR CUSTODY OF
THE JAIL WHO HAS A
EXPIRATION DATE.
NOT THOSE HERE ILLEGALLY.
EVERY INMATE IN OUR CARE HAS
THAT INFORMATION POSTED
ONLINE.
WE ARE NOT DESIGNATE BE
ANYBODY.
ANYBODY CAN SIFT THROUGH
THAT INFORMATION.
>> Sean: IF HE DOES DO
ANYTHING, I PROMISE YOU I
WILL DO EVERYTHING IN MY